y repasamos los titulares de la prensa
internacional con rosa pérez más de
euros a bienvenida a feliz jueves feliz
mañana vamos a comenzar con lo que
estábamos avanzando nuestro sumario la
bbc 26 la filtración de los documentos
que revela que las naciones presionaban
para cambiar el informe sobre el clima
rosa buenos días raúl exacto vamos a
empezar con este tema que es una
exclusiva una filtración de la bbc pero
de la cual se han hecho eco en medios
nacionales británicos e internacionales
porque precisamente no a lo que la bebé
se ha tenido acceso son a los documentos
son previos a este informe redactado por
él y psc que son las siglas en inglés de
panel intergubernamental por el cambio
climático esta organización que depende
en parte de naciones unidas- redacta
informes con las mayores evidencias
científicas disponibles para pues
proponer pues ciertas medidas y también
extraer conclusiones de la lucha contra
el cambio climático y estas conclusiones
estos informes se usan precisamente en
eventos en no cumbres como la cob y
exactamente rosas que este informe sale
a pocos días del inicio está con 26
exacto y precisamente lo que señalan
muchos analistas en este artículo es que
no es raro digamos que los distintos
países y organizaciones comenten el
borrador del informe antes de que esté
lista la versión final no según dicen a
los miembros del ipcc es un paso
fundamental para que todos los países
pues estén de acuerdo no y pues estén
todos en la misma página de la lucha
contra el cambio climático lo que sí
revela este informe pues es esta
diferencia no esta contradicción entre
lo que a veces pues declaran
públicamente los líderes de los estados
y lo que son sus intereses reales
nacionales no y en este informe pues hay
esto bueno en nuestras filtraciones
vemos presiones sobre pues rebajar la
urgencia o la magnitud de ciertas
medidas propuestas por esta organización
rosa pero aterrizamos todo este tema con
ejemplos concretos que nos trae pues por
ejemplo mira uno de los ejemplos que
señala este arte es la petición de
arabia saudita que solicita a los
científicos que eliminen la conclusión
siguiente el esfuerzo del sector
energético hacia la descarbonización
debe enfocarse rápidamente en las cero
emisiones y la eliminación de
combustibles fósiles pues arabia saudita
como mayor exportador de petróleo del
mundo pues no está interesado en que
figure esta conclusión en el informe por
otro lado también un alto funcionario
australiano que rechaza la necesidad de
cerrar plantas de carbón pues recordemos
no australia también gran productor de
carbón a nivel internacional por otro
lado pues brasil y argentina- rechazan
el hecho que reducir el consumo de carne
pues reduzca las emisiones de efecto
invernadero o pues por otro lado suiza
suiza o australia también cuestionan la
necesidad de que los países más ricos
deban financiar a los más pobres para la
implementación de energía verde así en
rosa vamos a cambiar ahora de tema el
'washington post' porque se encuentran
restos no identificados en la búsqueda
del prometido de la instaura mary grave
gaby apetito brian laudrup según las
autoridades esto rosa exacto mira este
caso ya lo comentamos en esta sección
hace unas semanas no sé si crees
necesario raúl que hagamos un cierto
100% o un repaso un contexto para el
caso no word que después como
comentábamos fue un caso muy mediático
en eeuu todavía lo es de hecho pero aquí
ha llegado quizá un poco menos la
cuestión es que esta chica gabi apetito
de 22 años estaba de viaje en una
furgoneta con su prometido bryant
londres pues alrededor de eeuu y como la
chica era instagramers pues iba
publicando y haciendo un seguimiento en
las redes pues de todo el periplo hasta
que desapareció pues apetito a mediados
de agosto
londres su prometido regreso a su casa
de florida semanas después en septiembre
se encontró el cuerpo de la chica de la
instala med mientras que su prometido
estaba a la fuga y pues cuando se hizo
la autopsia del caso del cuerpo de la
chica se encontró que había sido
asesinada con estrangulación y
precisamente la última noticia es que
ayer se encontraron también restos
humanos de momento sin identificar según
dice el fbi al lado de objetos
personales de que serían de brian
laundry del prometidos y que se presume
se puede presumir que es del prometido
rosa pérez tuvo un caso mediático que
también les permite sacar conclusiones
estructurales sobre este tema exacto por
eso ha sido como tan mediático no
digamos pues hay hay distintos puntos a
destacar por un lado evidentemente y con
todo lo que se ha hablado sobre
instagram facebook redes sociales en
estos sus últimos días pues como la vida
que uno proyecta sobre instagram puede
enmascarar muchas cosas por otro lado
también se ha señalado pues el llamado
síndrome de la mujer blanca desaparecida
porque precisamente pues este mismo
artículo del washington post señala unos
datos interesantes que es durante una
semana cuando estaba pues más caliente
este tema en los medios de eeuu fox news
por ejemplo mencionó trescientos noventa
y ocho veces el nombre de gabri apetito
en una semana tienen 346 veces
y se hace esta comparación con el caso
de la desaparición de una mujer blanca
respecto pues a mujeres y otras personas
realizadas a las que no se le da la
misma atención mediática y bueno ya otra
cuestión estructural se la podemos ver
ya en el siguiente artículo que hemos
preparado de la revista magazine
feminicidio y la necesidad de nombrar
los asesinatos por cuestión de género de
femenino en los eeuu rosa rápidamente ya
tengo que pasar unas invitado al día
pues muy rápidamente este artículo
señala la necesidad de que se enmarquen
o de que ese nombre como feminicidio los
asesinatos por violencia de género no
particularmente pues contra las mujeres
para poder tener una visión global y
estructural de la que es esta violencia
rosa gracias a por toda la información
mañana viernes nos vemos con más
titulares de la prensa internacional
ahora sigamos con nuestro primer
invitado del día gracias rosa
[Música]